Which ones did you think, David?
>> So the first sentence,
colorless green ideas sleep furiously.
I recognized pretty quickly as
a pretty famous example proposed
by Noam Chomsky of how sentences can
be semantically nonsensical, but
still grammatically correct.
The sentence makes sense.
There's still a subject, a verb,
an adverb describing the verb, but
the idea of a colorless
green idea makes no sense.
The idea of ideas sleeping makes
maybe a little bit of sense.
The idea of sleeping furiously
is kind of nonsense.
So the sentence really doesn't
have much meaning even though
it is grammatically correct.
The second sentence, soft drinks
due from thank bills insurance
really doesn't make
any grammatical sense.
It does have a seeming subject and
a seeming verb.
But the verb comes right a preposition
suggesting that the verb fills in
the slot proposed by the preposition,
which doesn't make any sense.
So this one doesn't make any
grammatical sense to me.
The same can be said for
the other two negative examples.
They don't really have the normal
subject, predicate sentence structure or
they have other rules or
constraints that are being violated.
For the other two positive examples,
they still maintain this subject
verb sentence structure.
So here we have wall decor notifies,
which doesn't make sense but
it matches our structure.
And here we have Tuesday brought
something, which also makes
no semantic sense, but can still be
thought of as grammatically correct.
Similarly, Tuesday bringing
something does make some sense, but
a a sharp-edged suite of pumpernickel
makes no sense whatsoever.
>> Note the vocabulary that David used
in trying to find out which of these
sentences were grammatically correct.
It seemed to me that he was examining
if the structure of these sentences
was fulfilling certain conditions or
fulfilling certain constraints
that he expects from his knowledge
of English-language grammar.
One could even say that he was
doing constraint processing.